je voulais montrer quelque chose qui ne
soit pas une illusion
quelque chose de réel
quelque chose qu'ils puissent voir et
toucher
la création
est un acte de pure panique
la vie
trouve toujours un chemin
[Musique]
on ne peut pas la garder ici
s'il la trouve on la reverra jamais on
doit la protéger c'est notre rôle
[Musique]
les humains et les dinosaures ne peuvent
pas coexister
a provoqué une catastrophe écologique
[Musique]
et les sacs leur alan grant
ne me dis pas que tu es venu jusqu'ici
pour évoquer le bon vieux temps tu es
bien ou pas
[Musique]
on court vers l'extension de notre
espèce
non seulement on ne domine pas la nature
mais on y est soumis
[Musique]
tu reviens je reviens toujours
c'est un avion ça pas vraiment
[Musique]
buffo plus gros pourquoi faut-il qu'il
soit toujours plus gros
[Musique]